hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
barstool sports Walmart Amazon or
Spencer Gifts play along with us it's
good what's up its your boy KFC and this
is final Berg welcome back to debate the
internet where we break down and the
most highly contested questions from
answer the internet today we're breaking
down a all-time classic one of the first
questions we ever did would you rather
for the rest of your life walk around
with a roller blade on your left foot or
have an angry [ __ ] walking through an
angry little person walking right in
front of you just a little bit slower
than you want to go everywhere you go
for the rest of your life
little person dwarf [ __ ] this is an
easy one for me I'm taking the [ __ ]
little person dwarf whatever I think
it's actually a pro I think it's a good
thing this is supposed to be bad I'm
gonna walk into this joint I'll be the
life of the party who shows up with a
little person it's like a it's like a
party trick it's like you brought the
you brought the show with you no one's
ever gonna forget you you're always
gonna stand out you're the guy with the
best pal who's a little person it's like
having Danny DeVito walk around with you
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's absolutely not like having Danny
DeVito walk around with you because the
little little person he's got a very bad
attitude Danny DeVito is a saint who we
are all lucky to live on the same planet
at the same time as the answer is
undoubtedly it's the rollerblade and
that's for a handful of reasons the
number one being that I am I'm addicted
to pornography so I'm always late to
things and if you have a roller blade
you get there so much that I leave my
apartment five minutes after I are
supposed to be there at all times so
best-case scenario I am always thirty
minutes late if I had a roller blade on
I'm getting there I mean you just see me
cruising down 5th Ave like just just
whipping around like what's that guy
with this futuristic
form of transportation that makes him
just blow past me and
to the speed of that people have him
being I don't know maybe only 12 minutes
late for things that's if that's a big
win for someone like me yeah it's true
this little person he's angry guess what
so am i he has a bad attitude yep me too
this is like having a little clone of
myself walking around with me I don't
want some guy who's sunshine and
rainbows I want some guy when I walk by
something like ah [ __ ] that he's like
yeah [ __ ] that
this person sucks huh yeah they do it's
like you're walking around with
permanent reinforcements permanent
confirmation bias with me and my little
person hanging out all day long Frank
Frank Frank Frank that's the answer is
brink brink if you don't know is the
best movie of all time it's a
rollerblading film available on Disney
Plus now I'll turn it into an ad I don't
give up [ __ ] if you could be one-half
the man actually hang on I can just put
another row blade on my other foot I'll
have two rollerblades I just started
this cuz I'm a [ __ ] genius in real
time I will just wear two rollerblades
that's a [ __ ] loophole that's
cheating and you know it that's I won't
wear two real boots when I get to the
place I desire to be I will take one off
and sit in a chair when I'm standing up
I will have two rollerblades on I was
gonna say if you could be half the man
Erich von den is you're lucky I'll be
the full male get a pair Arby's pair of
[ __ ] grinding down poles team pup n
suds what up I'm a blader now I'm gonna
blade but the problem is one roller
blade or two we're talking about in the
shower we're talking about when you
sleep at night we're talking about when
you have sex when you go to your
grandma's funeral you want to be the guy
who's got to go up to pay his respects
to grandma and you're just kicking
around
I don't think so absolutely that would
maybe feel a little bit fun but other
times not so convenient you're on the
crowded subway you're at it you're
trying to sit down to a nice dinner you
try to impress a girl why do you have
[ __ ] one roller blade on you weirdo
come on we're all about being normal
here you walk around with with one
roller blade you're not normal I'm sure
people are thinking of John you're
you're gay I said first of all I said is
lead to pornography not homosexual
pornography second of all ever
every way every mode of transportation
is gay like anything but walking is gay
that's just a fact this is a razor
scooter why doesn't he get the gay jokes
about him I one of those dudes I'm like
the unicycle scooters now with that
we're [ __ ] helmets like losers
bicycling bicycling is supremely
homosexual so I'm not worried about
there's no like there's no straight way
to get around other than walking slowly
like this that's the only way so sure
I'll have my rollerblades on and I look
like a gay boy all around town but I
will get there faster than you that's
that's the point
all right gay well you may be cruising
around town but do you know what I have
basically a personal assistant I've got
a guy to carry your stuff you know when
you got like you got too much stuff in
your pockets guys can't walk around with
purses cuz that is definitely gay you
just got this [ __ ] to carry your stuff
here man take my wallet Hey Dude carry
this bag for me yeah why don't you wait
online for me while I go over here he's
just he's just there it's just an extra
body again it's like having a little
clone to do all the kind of crappy [ __ ]
you don't want to do make the angry
dwarf do all the things you hate all
right the defense rests
let us know what you think roller blade
on your left foot and your little person
walking in front of you just a little
bit slower for the rest of your life
leave a comment below let us know who
won and make sure you rate and subscribe
you